شكرا لك محمد واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
التغطيه المستمره لتداعيات الزلزال المدمر
في تركيا وسوريا والبدايه بالعناوين
في تركيا الجهود لانقاذ تتواصل بحثا عن
ناجين تحت الانقاض واعداد ضحايا الزلزال
تتجاوز 17 الف قتيل وسته وستين الف مصاب
البرلمان يصادق على اعلان حاله الطوارئ في
الولايات المنكوبه وفي تاكيد رسمي اكثر من
1400 هزه ارتداديه منذ وقوع الكارثه
في سوريا نحو 4000 قتيل وشبح الوقت يحاصر
فرق الانقاذ مع تعثر دخول المساعدات
اللازمه الى شمال غربي البلاد وفي تفاقم
للماساه تصدعات في احد السدود المائيه
جراء الزلزال تغرق مناطق المخيمات بالمياه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينقضي اليوم الرابع للزلزال
للمدمر الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا
على مزيد من الضحايا حيث تكشف الساعات عن
زياده مفزعه تركيا تتجاوز حاجز سبعه عشر
الف قتيل
وسته وستين الف جريح وسوريا تقارب اربعه
الاف فيما يحاصر الوقت المنقذين السعين
للبحث عن ارواح يحول الركام بينها وبين
النجاه وبينما تعلن تركيا التصديق على
حاله الطوارئ في المدن المنكوبه تعاني مدن
شمال السوري من نقص يحول بينها وبين ادراك
ما يمكن ادراك
اللهم
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
كل دقيقه بحساب كل ثانيه بنفس كل امين
اشاره كل صوت بشاره كل سكون نهايه هكذا
يمر الوقت ثقيلا بطيئا في الامل وسريعا في
العمل على عمال الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
وهم يحيطون باقوام الدمار في سباق على
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه يرخون السمع علهم
يرصدون نبض الحياه وهم يتسلقون ما كانت
قبل ساعات غرفه نوم او مطبخ او معيشه ما
كانت حياه كامله
انقضت وامام الردم يتجمع اهالي العالقين
بامل ينفتح امامهم عند كل هتاف او تصفيق
باخراج احياء بينما يجلس اخرون بلا حيله
يتخيلون من كانوا ورحلوا في لحظات بانقضاء
اكثر من 60 ساعه تتراجع الامال بايجادنا
يتحدث الخبراء والاطباء عن قاعده الاربعه
حيث يمكن للانسان ان يعيش اربع دقائق دون
هواء واربعه ايام دون ماء واربعه اسابيع
دون طعام ان كان ذا بنيه قويه لكن القواعد
تصطدم بايات الاجال فترى اخراج رضيع لم
يتجاوز عمره اياما وصغار وكبار ربما
ساعدهم في النجاه وضعهم ومكانهم خلال
الزلزال او لوجود منفذ لماء او هواء في كل
الحالات يزيد عدد الضحايا ويكبر مع الوقت
بوتيره سريعه مع تقلص امال النجاه وفي
الوجه الاخر للماساه تتعاظم تحديات مواجهه
النكبه الانسانيه لمن باتوا بلا ماوى وهم
بمئات الالاف في البلدين الفزعه العالميه
لنجده الضحايا تواصلت لكن في شمال سوريا
حيث يختلط الحزن بالاستغاثه بحفر الارض
باليدين في غياب معدات ورافعات حديثه يقول
دفاع المدني ان الامال تتضائل بالعثور على
احياء وان المستشفيات العاجزه اصلا قد
بلغت اقصى قدرتها الوضع الماساوي يتطلب
مساعدات والمساعدات عالقه في سراضي
بالسياسه وتعقيدات الوضع السوري الذي لم
يجد فيه مجلس الامن ما يستدعي جلسه طارئه
لفتح المعابر الخاضعه لاليه دوليه بقرار
منه حيث تمر المساعدات عبر تركيا واعلنت
الامم المتحده الخميس ادخال ست شاحنات
اغاثه غذائيه وطبيه من معبر باب الهوى
وقال مسؤولون السوريون ان جزءا منها كان
مبرمجا من قبل وكلها تبقى ضئيله تكاد لا
ترى امام هول الكارثه في الجانب التركي
تجاوز عدد فرق الانقاذ الدوليه سته الاف
من 56 دوله فيما اقر الضمان فرض حاله
الطوارئ في عشر ولايات منكوبه هي اضنه
وايديامان وديار بكر وهاتاي وعثمانيه
وكهرمان مراش واورفا وكيليس وملاطيا وغازي
عنتاب انه اليوم الرابع وكل ما في المشهد
خانق كان الارض صغرت الى كومه حطام هناك
حيث يجلس احياء ينتظرون والباقي من الزمن
قليل
معنى من غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر
ابو نبوت ومن سلقين في ادلب مراسلة
ومن معبر باب الهوى عند الحدود السوريه
التركيه مراسل الجزيره ادهم ابو حسام نبدا
من غازي عنتاب مع منتصر منتصر عندما يحل
الظلام وتنخفض درجات الحراره الى حدود
الصفر وربما الى مادون ذلك كيف تستمر
عمليات الانقاذ ورفع الانقاض
حقيقه الان نحن نعمل على خفض صوتنا لاننا
في موقع
يحاول نعم يريدون منا
طيب
منتصر بما انه الان هو مرحله صمت ومرحله
الصمت يعني ان هناك فقط
نعم تحاولون الاستماع لاشخاص نعم نعم
عندما عندما تنتهي هذه العمليه عندما يتم
التاكد ان كان هناك اشخاص تحت الانقاض
وهذا ما نتمناه دائما ان تكون هناك اصوات
تصدر من تحت الانقاذ نعود اليك منتصر ابو
نبوت ربما السؤال نفسه يوجه الى عمر حلبي
من ريف ادلب لان الطبيعه هي نفسها
والمصيبه ايضا هي نفسها عمرو في ظل موجات
البرد والصقيع هذه والتي كانت باديه
بالفعل بشكل كبير كيف تستمر عمليات
الانقاذ ورفع الانقاض
ظروف صعبه الحقيقه حسن ظروف صعبه هي
الظلام دامس طقس شديد البروده كما تحدثنا
دائما نحن قبل ان نتجهز فقط للايف او
للمقابله وخلال هذه الدقائق خصوصا عندما
تكون المقابلات خلال المساء او ساعات
الصباح الاولى نكاد صدقا ان نتجمد حسن من
شده البرد فما بالك بهؤلاء النازحين الذين
اضطروا لترك منازلهم او الذين يعملون في
عمليات الانقاذ في ظروف هذه شديده البروده
الطقس بارد الظلام حالك الكهرباء منقطعه
الظروف الانسانيه بالغه الصعوبه في هذا
المكان الذي انا فيه اضطر العناصر الدفاع
المدني قبل قليل لاخذ قسط من الراحه كلمني
قائد المجموعه الذي كان هنا واخبرني انهم
كانوا يعملون على مدى ثمانيه واربعين ساعه
متواصله بعد ساعات العمل يستخرجوا او خلال
ساعات العمل الماضيه استمكنوا من استخراج
نحو 50 جثه من هذا الموقع الان المشكله
بان الظلام شديد والا كانت الكاميرا
اردتكم حجم الدمار الهائل هذه ساحه اصبحت
ساحه لكن كانت هناك عده مباني اصبحت الان
حتى الحجاره فتت بفعل عمليات البحث عن
ناجينه او عن ضحايا تحت
الانقاض بالتالي هنالك ثلاثه جثث كما
اخبرنا الدفاع المدني لا تزال تحت الانقاض
لكنهم يواصلون عمليات البحث وحتى الان لم
يتمكنوا من العثور عليها في مواقع اخرى
اليوم نحن مررنا بالعديد من المواقع
المدمره سواء في ريف ادلب وفي ريف حلب من
اعزاز شرقا وحتى سلقين هنا غربا مررنا
باحد المواقع حسن وكنا قد راينا اناس
ومدنيون كانوا يقومون بعمليات البحث
وبالتاكد من عدم وجود جثث تحت الانقاض
بايديهم
وباستخدام ادوات بسيطه للغايه الدفاع
المدني كان يعمل نعم في تلك المواقع لكنه
ذهب الى اماكن اخرى كان فيها ناجون على ما
كان يبدو تحت الانقاض فذهب لانتشارهم في
تلك المواقع انها اعمله فيها ثم المدنيون
بادوات بسيطه كانوا يواصلون اعمالهم في
الطرقات التي عندما مررنا كنا نرى الناس
يعيشون الطرق عمل سنعود اليك لكن لنستمع
الى جانب من كلام وزير الداخليه التركي في
هذا الشان فيما يتعلق بالكارثه
وايضا اصلاح الماء وايضا عمليات الاجلاء
وطبعا كل هذه الامور
هناك من
المواضيع التي
يجب ان نقف عندها
في مثلا المخيمات
التي
ايضا تحتاج الى
القدر
تحتاج الى تدفئه والمساعدات
وايضا
تحتاج الى الخدمات
من الجيش ايضا الى
الفرق الانقاذ الشرطه
وقوات الدرك وقوات المسلحه
اكثر من عشرين الف شخص يشاركنا في عمليه
الانقاذ والبحث
تقريبا تقريبا 20,000 شخص الان يعملون على
عمليه الانقاذ وفقا لاخر الارقام
ان خمس الاف وخمسمائه
وثلاثه وعشرين في كهرباء مراش
قتلوا نتمنى من الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
[موسيقى]
يرحمهم ويشفي الجرحى دفنا اكثر من 4000
شخص حتى الان
[موسيقى]
طبعا
وذلك
بتنسيق بين الادعاء العام
مشاهدينا هذا جانب من كلام لوزير الداخليه
التركيه حول جهود
الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ ومساعده المنكوبين
في المناطق التي ضربها هذا الزلزال نتابع
ما تبقى من كلام وزير الداخليه عبر قناه
الجزيره مباشر ونعود الى مراسلينا نعود
الى منتصر ابو نبود في غازي عنتاب منتصر
يعني هل صدر هذا الصوت الذي تركناك لكي لا
يعلو صوتك امامه
صحيح حسن نحن الان بدايه نريد ان انوه الى
المنطقه نحن في منطقه الابراهيملي حي
الابراهيمي في غازي عنتاب قبل قليل عندما
بدانا في هذه المداخله اطفئت جميع الاليات
اطفات الاضويه لسماع صوت من تحت الانقاض
وفعلا سمعنا هذا الصوت ثم تم تحديد الموقع
واشعلت
الاضواء وتم تشغيل الاليات وعادوا الى
عمليات البحث والانقاذ لكنهم عادوا
بالادوات المعدات الخفيفه لانها حتى لا
يقع ضررا بالاشخاص الذين هم تحت الانقاذ
اوقفوا الاليات الثقيله يمكن من خلال هذه
الصور التي تشاهدونها مباشره الغاز عين
تاب لهذا المبنى
الذي تجري فيه عمليات البحث تحت الانقاذ
قبل قليل كما ذكرت تم تحديد موقع لشخص على
ما يبدو انه لا يزال على قيد الحياه ثم
عادت جهود البحث بعد ان تم تحديد الجهه
التي صدر منها الصوت يكون تكثيف البحث
والحفر في تلك في تلك الجهه وفي ذلك
الجانب كما تشاهدون هذه الصور يمكن ان
نترك
الصور
لثواني حتى ننقل الصوره ويعيش المشاهد
مباشره مع
الاوضاع التي تعيشها مدينه غازي عنتاب
هذه الصوره نعم حسن
بانه رغم مرور كل هذه الايام ربما ما تزال
تصدر اصوات لاحياء ما زالوا تحت الانقاض
نتمنى ان تكلل هذه المحاوله بالنجاح وان
يتمكن تتمكن هذه الفرق من اخراج محاصرين
تحت الركام وهم على قيد الحياه تفضل منتصر
نعم اريد التنويه لان هذا المبنى الذي
يجري في عمليه البحث تحت الانقاض هنالك
مباني اخرى مهدمه بالكامل وايضا تجري في
عمليه البحث عمليه البحث لا تجري فقط هنا
هذا الحي يوجد اكثر من ثلاثه ابنيه او
اربعه ابنيه قد هدمت بشكل كامل وايضا
عندما تم ايقاف عمليات البحث والحفر تم
ايقافها في كل هذا الشارع ايضا هذا الشارع
يوجد فيه عدد من الاشخاص الذين نجوا من
هذه الابنيه ولهم قيام موجوده بالقرب من
هنا نصبها الهلال الاحمر بالاضافه الى
نقطه طبيه لهلال الاحمر وايضا الى فرق
الانقاذ وفرق الاطفاء والفرق الاسعاف
ينتشرون في هذا المكان بالاضافه الى
الشرطه التركيه وكل
وكل يعني
الاشخاص الذين يمكنهم المساعده في عمليه
الانقاذ في جهود الانقاذ الان تشاهدون هذه
الاليه مثلا هذه الاليات الثقيله توقفت عن
العمل حتى لا تؤذي الاشخاص تحت الانقاذ ثم
عاد العمل كما ذكرت
طبعا كل هذا يجري يعني في ظروف صعبه نتحدث
عن وقت طويل مره وهم تحت الانقاذ في درجات
حراره متدنيه نشاهد هذا الشارع يمكن ان
يكشف اكثر عن حجم البحث وايضا حجم الدمار
الذي حل به والابنيه التي سقطت في هذا
الشارع
نعم طيب
نتمنى كما قلنا ان تكلل تلك
المحاولات بالنجاح واذا ما حصل
ان كان هناك من هو على قيد الحياه وتم
انتشاله بطبيعه الحال سنعود اليك منتصر
ابو نبوت لمتابعه هذه المحاوله على انها
تكون على الهواء مباشره ايضا انتقل الى
معبر باب الهوى مع ادهم ابو الحسام ادهم
حركه المعبر كيف بدات اليوم
مع الحديث عن دخول مساعدات فتح المعبر من
وقت الى اخر اخبرنا عن الوضع على هذا
المعبر
حسن للاسف في الوقت الذي من المفترض به ان
نغطي دخول المساعدات الانسانيه والاستجابه
الطارئه الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا جراء
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه ونحن في
اليوم الرابع ولكن للاسف رائحه الموت تفوح
من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا كل
نصف ساعه تقريبا مكتب الخاص في اداره معبر
الباب الهوى في لدفن الموتى يستلم جثامين
الضحايا الذين قضوا في عده ولايات في
تركيا ويتم نقلهم الى هذا المكان خلفي
تقريبا
نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 500 وخمسه وعشرين
جثمان كانوا قد وصلوا الى هذا المعبر الذي
نقف فيه حاليا في عمق الصوره تظهر البوابه
الرئيسيه لمعبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع
تركيا والذي من المفترض ان تدخل المساعدات
الى هذه المناطق من هذه البوابه
منذ قليل قبل ان نظهر في هذه المداخله
دخلت خمسه جثامين تم استلام ثلاثه جثامين
من قبل عائلاتهم واقربائهم هنا في سوريا
واثنين من الضحايا تم وضعهم في ثلاجه
مخصصه لحفظ الموتى متواجده في هذا الكراج
مقابل البوابه الرئيسيه عشرات العائلات
طيله ساعات الليل والنهار وفي هذا البرد
القارس تنتظر وصول جثامين ابنائها
وامهاتها وابائها الذين قضوا جراء الزلزال
الذي ضرب عده ولايات في تركيا الاوضاع
الانسانيه سيئه للغايه مع نظره المساعدات
الانسانيه التي كانت من المفترض ان تدخل
منذ اليوم الاول الذي ضرب زلزال هذه
المنطقه حتى هذه الساعه نستطيع ان نؤكد
منذ اليوم الاول وحتى هذه الساعه لم يدخل
سوى قافله تحمل
لست شاحنات تتضمن مساعدات انسانيه
واستجابه طارئه هي ضمن برنامج الدعم
الاممي الذي كان نفرض ان تدخل قبل الزلزال
اضافه الى ست شاحنات تحمل مواد من فحم
الفيرين تم توزيعها تباعا الى المتضررين
وحسب الحاجه والاولويه
للعائلات نتحدث عن احتياجات كبيره لمنطقه
تفتقر الى الكوادر الطبيه تفتقر الى
التجهيزات المستشفيات تفتقر الى كل
احتياجات البحث والاجلاء فرق الدفاع
المدني تطلب ايضا من المنظمات الانسانيه
ومنظمه افاد للكوارث بادخال معدات ثقيله
لاستكمال عمليات الانقاذ في سلقين وايضا
في جنديرس الق على العمل الان حسن في هذه
السياره تصل الجثامين
في هذه السيارات تصل الجثامين الى داخل
هذا المكان المخصص لاحظ لهفه الاهالي
وذويه ضحايا كيف يتراكضون الى هذه السياره
لربما
يعني يصلون الى حتى حتى بات امنهم ان تصل
جثمان عائلاتهم التي قضت في تركيا نعم
حقيقه حسن الموقف
موقفان موقفان من تداعيات الزلزال الموقف
الاول وهو شعور قاسي جدا لاناس ينتظرون
ناجين من تحت الانقاض وايضا شعور اخر هو
صعب حقيقه
لعائلات تنتظر الضحايا التي تصل من تركيا
تباعا نتحدث نعود اذكر بالرقم وصل الى هذه
المنطقه اكثر من 500
ضحيه قضت داخل الولايات التركيه منذ اليوم
الاول وحتى هذه الساعه حسن القائمين على
العمل الانساني يناشدون المنظمات
الاقليميه والدوليه بضروره توفير مستشفيات
ميدانيه وايضا مرافق خدميه
والخيام لتدارك الوضع الانساني لربما
يتفاقم مع توقعات بارتفاع اعداد الضحايا
خصوصا نحن دخلنا اليوم الرابع هو هو وقت
حساس لوجود تحت
الحدود التركيه السوريه وشكرا لعمر حلبي
كان معنا من سلقين بريفي ادلب ومنتصر ابو
نبوت كان معنا من غازي عنتاب
مشاهدينا عمل فرق البحث والانقاذ يعد عند
وقوع كوارث طبيعيه اساسيا في عمليه انقاذ
وانتشال ناجين من تحت الانقاض لا سيما في
الايام الاولى للكارثه فريق الجزيره رفق
فريق انقاذ من تركيا في ملاطيا التركيه
ورصد جانبا من الصعوبات التي تواجه مهمتهم
تعمل فرق الانقاذ في حالات الطوارئ
والكوارث الطبيعيه سؤال ربما يتبادر الى
اذهان الكثيرين ونحن نتساءل ايضا سنكون
اليوم في رفقه احد فرق الانقاذ
وصلنا الى الموقع الذي ستعمل فيه فرق
الانقاذ هناك منهم من دخل بالفعل قائد
الفريق الان يعطي توجيهاته
للافراد الذين سيشاركون
في البحث في هذا المكان
سندخل المرحله الاولى هذه الاليه الثقيله
ستفتح الطريق امام فريق الانقاذ ليبدا
العمل وطبعا الجميع هنا يعمل بتوجيهات
وبامراض قائد الفريق
هو من يحرك الاليات الثقيله ويشير اليهم
ما هي الطريق التي يحتاجها الفريق وايضا
يقوم بتقسيم الفريق لا يدخل كامل الفريق
مره واحده يتم تقسيمه الى مجموعات
[موسيقى]
يوجه الان الفريق للصمت التام
اذا انتهت فتره الصمت
لم يستطيعوا سماع اي
صوت صادر من تحت الانقاض
يتقدم قائد الفريق
مع عدد من المنقذين طبعا نحن نتحرك معهم
ولكن ببطء وبموافقتهم طبعا يحاولون تحديد
مكان
بثغره يمكن احداثها
لارسال معدات للاستكشاف كاميرا في مرحله
من المراحل وان تمكنوا من احداث ثغره اوسع
قد يرسلون اشخاص من الفريق الى الداخل
هناك سؤال مهم نتوجه به لقائد الفريق متى
تفقدون الامل
نتمسك دوما بالامل تمكننا من انتشال ناجين
بعد مرور اربعه ايام على الزلزال ننطلق
دائما من افتراض ان جميع منهم تحت الانقاض
لا يزالون على قيد الحياه
صعبه
هنا بها وجميع المشاعر التي تعتريهم وهم
يعملون على مواقع كهذه هم يتعاملون مع بشر
وهم بشر لديهم احاسيس ولديهم مشاعر ولكن
يضعون مسؤولياتهم في الدرجه الاولى هكذا
ابلغونا خلال مرافقتنا لهم في هذا اليوم
سلام خضر الجزيره مالاتيا جنوب تركيا
معنى من كهرمان مراش في جنوب تركيا
ابراهيم اوزير مدير اداره الكوارث في
الهلال الاحمر التركي مرحبا بك سيدي
ابراهيم
هناك سؤال
هل الافتراض بوجود احياء في مبنى معين
منهار
يكون بالصدفه ام بناء على معلومه ام ماذا
او على شكل سقوط المبنى ام ماذا
عدد من الاسباب والمعايير
تحدد مستوى الضرر عندما تكون هناك هزه
ارضيه فان نوعيه البناء هو العنصر الرئيسي
لمعرفه مستوى التاثير هذا اول عنصر وثم
هناك الارض
ونوعيه التربه وطريقه
بناء هذه المباني
هناك عده معايير بالتاكيد ولكن هيكل
البناء هو السبب الرئيسي والانعيار الاول
نعم ولكن ليس سؤالي هنا سؤالي انتم
كمسعفين او منقذين
علامه تعتمدون عندما تفترضون ان في هذا
البناء المدمر قد يكون هناك
احياء تحت الركام
اذا ما فهمت سؤالك بس شكل صحيح انه انه
نكتس كيف يمكن فرق الانقاذ ان تقرر اي
مبنى يبداون به او هل يمكن ان ننقذ الناس
من الركام بدي اجيب على سؤالين هذه هذا
الزلزال في هذه هذا والظرف فيه هناك طريقه
فريده من نوعها فهي اصابه عشره مدن واكثر
من 30 مدينه وقريه صغيره ايضا وهذا يعني
انه في الوقت ذاته لابد لك مئات من اعضاء
الفرق البحثي هو انقاذ لانقاذ الناس ولكن
الصعوبه تبدا بهيكل البناء اذا كانت بنايه
عاليه جدا او اذا كانت ارضيتها ناعمه
مثلا لدينا عده طوابق للمبنى انهارت فهذا
طبعا يعني تتحول الى ثلاثه طوابق فقط وهذا
لدينا معدات ومكان لازاله هذا الركام
الكبير لو التاكد من الناس مع التاكد مع
ان الناس اللي تحت الانقاذ لا يتصابون
باضرر واذى ونخرجهم بامان هذه الاطراف
الصعبه وهذا وهذا ما يبغي ان تقوم به
وتقرره الفرق البحثي والانقاذ بناء على
وضع المبنى سيد ابراهيم اوزير
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بالاضافه الى الازمه التي سببها
هذا الزلزال بعدد الضحايا هناك ازمه
موازيه تتعلق بالمشردين سواء في المناطق
التركيه او السوريه المتضرره ويقدر عدد
متضررين من الزلزال بقرابه سته وعشرين
مليون شخص يعيشون ظروفا صعبه بلا ماوى ولا
ماء ولا كهرباء بينما تعبر منظمه الصحه
العالميه عن خشيتها من ان يفقد عدد من
هؤلاء حياتهم نتابع التقرير التالي ثم
نعود الى ضيفنا
ثمه اليوم التالي بعد كل كارثه صحيح ان
اعمال الانقاذ لا تزال مستمره في جنوبي
تركيا وشمال سوريا الا ان فرص العثور على
ناجين تبدا بالتضائل شيئا فشيئا
في اليوم التالي ينتظر الضحايا الاخرون
على الركاب
[موسيقى]
ينتظرون الانتهاء من احصاء القتلى والعثور
على الجثث ودفنها يقول مسؤولون اتراك ان
اكثر من 15 مليون شخص تضرروا في المناطق
التركيه بينما تقول الامم المتحده ان 11
مليون شخص تضرروا من الكارثه في المناطق
السوريه المنطقه اشبه بدائره نصف قطرها
اكثر من 150 كيلومترا مركزها هو مركز
الزلزال في كهرمان مرعش تلك ارقام تقريبيه
فقط
تحولت المنازل في تلك الدائره الى مهدمه
بالكامل او متصدعه غير مناسبه للسكن او
ممنوعه من الاستخدام حتى تفحص بشكل نهائي
ويقرر مصيرها بامكانيه استيعاب السكان ام
لا تتضاعف الازمه لدى اللاجئين السوريين
من الخمسه عشر مليون متضرر في المناطق
التركيه تمت اكثر من مليون وسبعمائه
في هذه الحاله تبدو خيارات الحكومه
التركيه محدوده في التعامل مع الازمه تقول
الحكومه انها وفرت اكثر من خمسين الف غرفه
فندقيه للهواء بحساب بسيط فان هذه الغرف
لن تتجاوز طاقتها الاستيعابيه اكثر من ربع
مليون شخص ما زال الحديث عن ارقام مهوله
هنا اما ان تتدفق الخيام والمنازل
المعدنيه الجاهزه الى هذه المقاطعات
المتضرره او ان ينجح هؤلاء الملايين الى
المناطق المجاوره الاقل تضررا
الى جانب كل ذلك تلفت منظمه الصحه
العالميه الى ازمه موازيه بدات ملامحها في
الخوف من تفاقم المخاطر الصحيه تطل بعض
الامراض الفتاكه براسها مثل الكوليرا
وامراض الجهاز التنفسي بالاضافه الى
الصدمات النفسيه العميقه ودون ماوى او ماء
او وقود او كهرباء تخشى منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان يفقد العديد من الناجنه
حياتهم
هكذا تتسع دائره الضحايا ذهب قرابه عشرين
الف شخص الى الموت حتى ساعه اعداد هذا
التقرير لكن ازمه تفاصيلها كثيره تنتظر
ملايين الاشخاص من الضحايا الاحياء في
اليوم التالي للكارثه
من جديد نعود اليك سيدي ابراهيم وزير من
كارمان مراش في جنوب تركيا تبعنا هذا
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن ازمه
ازمه وكارثه لها علاقه
بالمتضررين او المشردين في العراء كيف يتم
التعامل مع هذه الازمه سيدي ابراهيم
سالتك عن هؤلاء المشردين الذين اما تضررت
منازلهم او هدمت بالكامل وفي كلا الحالتين
لن يعودوا اليها ماذا يفعلون وكيف يتم
التعامل معهم
ان هؤلاء الناس الذين لا يستطيعوا العوده
الى مبانيهم
عليهم ان يتابعوا الاخبار القادمه من
السلطات والسلطات وهي الحكومه لابد تعطيهم
الموافقه للعوده الى منازلهم اذا ارادوا
ذلك ولكنك غالبيه من هؤلاء الناس لا
يمكنهم العوده الى منازلهم وبالتالي عندهم
بضعه خيارات
توجه لبعض الاقارب ليسكنوا معهم او قد
يكون لدي بعض الاقارب البعيدين في مدينه
اخرى لدوجه اليها لكن من اين من هذه هذه
الخيارين فان ذاك اما يقررون البقاء
قد يكون بعض
الانتظار اخراج بعض اقارب من تحت الركام
اذ يبقون قرب المباني المنهاره على امل ان
يخرج بقيه اقربائهم احياء ولن يتوجه الى
اي مكان يبقون حول المبنى المنهار اذا اما
يقظه كل وقتهم خارج المباني هذه ونحن نقوم
بتقديم البطانيات
واشياء اخرى ولكن اذا لم يرغبوا بالمغادره
فان ذلك لا بد ان نجد الطريق اخرى
للتدفئه انفسهم اما الخيار الثالث فان
السلطات
تنقلهم الى المدن اخرى حيث يجدوا بعض
بعض الماوى واماكن يبقوا فيها بامان
والدفع ونحن كسلطات ومنظمات نقدمه الطعام
الماء
وايضا هذه خيارات موجوده لمن يريد يبقى
ابن الدين او يغادرها من يبقى في المدينه
سيحصلون على
هناك مئات من
الخيم ستنصب في افضل جزء من المدينه من
حيث
نوعيه الارضيه
وبالتالي ما ان تن هذه الخيام فانا هؤلاء
الاشخاص ينقلون اليها ليبكوا فيها شكرا لك
ابراهيم وزير مدير اداره الكوارث في
الهلال الاحمر التركيه حدثتنا من كهرماش
في جنوبي تركيا
السلطات التركيه اليوم قالت اكثر من 1400
هزار ارتداديه وقعت منذ وقوع الكارثه
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وقد وقع في منطقه شديده الزلازل هذه
المنطقه هي واحده من اخطر المناطق في
البحر الابيض المتوسط الجزء الاوسط
الجنوبي من تركيا كان الاكثر تضررا كما
تشاهدون ووزاره النقل والبنيه التحتيه
التركيه تعتقد ان اجمالي
1275 كم من خطوط السكك الحديد قد تضررت
بشكل خطير من الزلزال الذي ضرب منطقه
كارمن مراش وفي اشاره الى التغييرات في خط
الصدى بعد الزلزال لفت البروفيسور كارلو
دودجيليوني رئيس المعهد الوطني الايطاليه
للجيو فيزياء والبراكين ان زلزله تركيا
تسبب في تحول جيولوجي ادى الى تحريك الواح
الغلاف الصخري بمقدار ثلاثه ام وهذا يعني
ان تركيا تحركت من مكانها ثلاثه امتار
ووفقا للعلم الايطالي حدث كل شيء في عشرات
الثواني ويبدو الامر كما لو ان تركيا قد
تحولت الى الجنوب الغربي
من روما معنى
رئيس المعهد الوطني الايطاليه للجيو
فيزياء
والبراكين دكتور هل لنا نفهم اكثر ماذا
يعني ان تركيا انزاحت
ثلاثه امتار باتجاه
الجنوب الغربي
مسائكم اولا
الصفيحه
الاناضليه
تتحرك كل يوم
بمسافات قليله
بضعه سنتيمترات في السنه تجاهها الجنوب
الغربي لكن الصفيحه
الاناضوليه في في الجانب الشرقي من هضبه
الاناضول القريبه من الصفيحه العربيه
اذا في هذه المنطقه التي هي
كما قلنا
قريبه من الصفيحه العربيه القشره اكتسبت
واختسمت كميات كبيره من الطاقه اذا في
الوقت الذي كانت فيه هي الصفيحه تتحرك نحو
الجنوب الغربي
والتماس مع الصفيحه العربيه كانت الحركه
هذه
تكتسب وتغتسم كميات من الطاقه التي تم
اطلاقها بشكل مفاجئ لان
الحجم هذا في هذا المكان لم يستطع استيعاب
المزيد من الطاقه اذا هناك عده
التصدعات
ظهرت لتسريب والتنفيس عن هذه الطاقه
وكذلك فان الحركه هذه
التي هي كانت ثلاثه امتار نقول بالحد
الادنى ثلاثه امتار ربما مع الهزه
الارتداديه الثانيه الرئيسيه التي
ربما كان الانزياح برمته من الناحيه
النظريه يمكن ان يكون خمسه او سته امتار
حتى اذا
الثلاثه امتار هي الحد الادنى التي
استخرجناها من حساب البيانات
في الهزه الارضيه في الايام القليله
المقبله عندما تتوفر البيانات من الاقمار
الاصطناعيه ستعطينا المزيد من التفاصيل
حول حركه الانحياز هذه بين الصفيحه
الامازوليه والصفيحه العربيه طيب ما هو
تاثير حركه الانحياز هذه
او الانزياح عفوا
الحركه هذه امر طبيعي تماما لان كل الهزات
الارضيه تؤدي الى حركات بين الجانبي او
جداري
الصدع او الخط الزلزالي واذا ما تتذكرون
حول زلزال طوكيو في 2011
الذي ضرب اليابان من جهه المحيط الهادئ
فان الحيازه قاع البحر في بعض الاماكن
بلغت حتى خمسين مترا خمسين متر امر مثير
للذهول اذا ثلاثه امتار هي في في ايطاليا
ايضا في 2016 الزلزال ايضا احدث حركه
بثلاثه امتار كان نوعا مختلفا من الحركه
لكن على اي اتحاد من الحركه ليس امرا
غريبا او كبيرا عندما
يتركز الزلزال او يكون الزلزال في صدع
معين
وعلى بعد مئات الكيلومترات عنه هناك صدع
اخر
هل هذا يؤثر على صدوع الاخرى يعني زلزال
مثلا كهرمان مراش هل بالضروره يؤثر على
صدوع موجوده في في سوريا وفي لبنان
هذا ما نسميه بسلوك بؤره الزلزال او مركز
الزلزال عندما يتم اطلاقه وتنفيس هذا من
الطاقه يكون قادرا على تحريك اماكن اخرى
من الغلاف الارضي او القشره الارضيه التي
تكون في قد وصلت كتله حرجه من الطاقه
وتخزين الطاقه لان اي مكان
تضربه هز ارضيه يكون هناك تخزين للطاقه
الذي يولدوا الضغط عندما يصل عتبه معينه
فان الهزه الارضيه تتم او تقع ربما يكون
هذا بسبب هزار سابقه تؤثر فيها وتحدثها
اذا حتى
حتى في زلزال ازميت في 1999 في شمال غرب
تركيا
خلقه وولد مجموعه من الهزات الارتداديه
بعد شهرين في هذه الحاله الهزه الارضيه
والزلزال الثاني كان اقرب من حيث الوقت
حوالي 10 ساعات بعد عشر ساعات تقريبا طبعا
هذه بردها الى ان بالنسبه
للكره الارضيه الثواني والدقائق والايام
كلها لا تعدو كونها شيئا صغيرا جدا من حيث
تخزين الطاقه الذي يتم على مدى الاف
السنوات شكرا لك من روما
ليوني رئيس المعهد الوطني الايطالي للجيو
فيزياء والبراكين
مشاهدينا ننتقل الان
لمتابعه تصريح لنائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد
اخطائي
المتنقله وايضا
جميع
المؤسسات في خدمه المنكورين ايضا بالنسبه
للماوى
ايضا لدينا فعاليات حول هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
وايضا نقوم
بعمليه الاجلاء
وحتى الان
نقوم بعمليات اجلاء لهذه المحافظات
الان نقوم باعمال
طبعا
رؤيه
الاضرار التي لحقت بالمباني
الاماكن طبعا
بذلك نحدد المباني التي لحق بها
الضرر والتي سيتم هدمها
منذ اليوم الاول وحتى الان
وصلنا الى
طبعا
المرحله مهمه في انجاز هذا التقرير
لان في المرحله التي ستاتي فيما بعد هي
مرحله الانشاء والبناء وتسليم الاشخاص
بيوتهم المقاومه للزلازل
طبعا ايضا
شيئا اخر هو متعلق بالدفن
واذا نلتفي بهذا القدر من تصريح لفادقتي
نائب الرئيس التركي ايضا
بشان
التداعيات والاثار الناجمه عن هذا الزلزال
المدمر في تركيا وسوريا
في سوريا قال الدفاع المدني في مناطق
الشمال السوري ان الالاف ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض وان عمليات الانقاذ وصلت الى نقطه
حرجه وانهم بحاجه الى دعم دولي وقد ارتفع
عدد القتلى في عموم سوريا الى 3000
و377 وتجاوز عدد المصابين خمسه الاف
ريق
[موسيقى]
من ريف ادلب معنا احمد يازيجي عضو مجلس
اداره الدفاع المدني السوري مرحبا بك سيد
احمد
ماذا عن عمليات
الانقاذ ورفع الانقاض وماذا عن الامكانيات
بالدرجه الاولى هذا الامر الذي
يشكو منه عناصر الدفاع المدني وفرق
الانقاذ منذ اللحظه الاولى في الشمال
السوري
ما زالت فرق الدفاع المدني الى حب اللحظه
تقوم بعمليات
البحث عن
العانقين تحت الانصاب ناسف ان نقول
فرص النجب هناك
اشخاص على قيد الحياه
مع اليوم الثالث الحصيل الان اشارت لدينا
1970 قديم بالاضافه الى 2950
نقول ايضا انه في الوقت في ساعات الصباح
الاولى لهذا اليوم
كانت اغلب
الذي تم اخراجهم من تحت الانقاذ قد فارق
الحياه ذلك بسبب
عده اسنان منها
الامكانيات التي كانت بين يديه الدفاع
المد بالاضافه ان هناك بعض النقاط معمل
الان على البحث والانقاذ للاسف لا يوجد
ارقام توضح مدى عدد الاشخاص المتواجدين
الان تحت الانقاذ والتي يتم البحث عن
طب لو عدنا الى الحديث عن عن الامكانيات
هل تغير الوضع شيئا فشيئا منذ اليوم الاول
وحتى اليوم مع المناشدات التي اطلقت عبر
اكثر من منبر ومن اكثر من جهه
[موسيقى]
كانت هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات دوريه تقوم
بها الامم المتحده وقد ادلت دخولها بسبب
الزلزال وتظهر المعبره اذا هي لم تكن
مساعدات
لم تكن هي مساعدات تخص الثالث التي حصلت
شكرا لك احمد مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني
السوري حدثنا من ريفي في ادلب
افاد مراسل الجزيره نقلان عن مصادر في
المعارضه السوريه ان النظام السوري فتح
بوابات السد الرسل شمال محافظه حمص خوفا
من تاثيرات الزلزال وقد تسبب فتح السد في
ارتفاع منسوب مياه نهر العاصي اضاف
مراسلنا ان مياه نار العصيد دمرت جزءا من
سد ترابيه قرب بلده تلول ما ادى لوصول
المياه الى بيوت القريه ونزوح سكانها
هذه اقرب نقطه استطعنا الوصول اليها قريبا
من السد الترابي الذي انهار بفعل فيضان
نهر العاصي هذا السد كان كان يحجب مياه
النهر الى
عن هذه القريه لكن فيضان النهر بعد
الزلزال دفع بالمياه الى الحاجز الترابي
او السد الترابي فانهار بشكل سريع وانطلقت
المياه الى بيوت القريه ستظهر الكاميرا
الطائره ستظهر حجم الكارثه التي تعرضت لها
هذه القريه حيث اجتمع الزلزال ومياه النهر
فدمر الزلزال العديد من البيوت اكثر من 20
بيت في هذه القريه وادى الى تصدع الحاجز
الترابي او السد الترابي ثم غرقت بيوت
القريه في المياه واضطره سكان هذه البيوت
الى المغادره خلال ساعات الليل ليس ذلك
فقط بل ان هذه القريه تحوي على مخيم
للنازحين مثل البلدات التي تقع على خط
الحدود السوريه التركيه سكان هذا المخيم
اضطروا ايضا
للخروج من هذا المخيم ليستقروا في مخيمات
اخرى بعيدا او في منطقه اعلى من هذا
المكان نهر العاصي يمر بجوار هذه القريه
ويظهر هنا مفارقه الحياه والموت ان يكون
النهر سببا للحياه او سببا للموت وخلال
تاريخهم استطاع سكان المنطقه تطويع مياه
النهر لكن زلزال دمر حساباتهم واستطاعت
المياه اخيرا مياه نهر العاصي ان تصل الى
بيوتهم واشد ما يخاف منه السكان ان تدمر
البيوت لان هذه البيوت مبنيه على التراب
كما اخبرنا سكان القريه فهنا لا توجد
منطقه صخريه صهيب الخلف الجزيره من بلده
تلول ريف ادلب